na minha época de escola eu era uma
típica adolescente ansiosa
só que no meu caso também muito realista
e pragmática
então me lembro que há 17 anos eu já
estava me sentindo atrasada para
resolver o que queria fazer da vida e eu
ficava me perguntando qual será a forma
mais rápida e mais legal de chegar no
mundo inteiro e inspirar mudanças
será que a gente podia por exemplo
melhorar o mundo sentado no sofá
assistindo filmes e comendo pipoca
eu pensava muito nisso porque eu
aprendia muito quando via filmes então
insistir nessa ideia foi estudar cinema
e começar a buscar referências que me
trouxesse uma conexão real entre filmes
e mudanças e aí foi quando eu assisti um
tédio de um produtor canadense de cinema
que já estava colocando em prática um
conceito parecido de cinema como
transformação social
ele é minha maior inspiração até hoje eu
me lembro que eu já fiz qual dizia essa
apresentação que para a gente melhorar o
mundo além de acabar com esse abismo de
oportunidades que existe hoje
a gente precisa também acabar com a
visão da esperança e contando boas
histórias
a gente pode começar a inspirar em poder
às pessoas diminuindo esse abismo
naquele momento eu comecei a perceber o
quanto a esperança de fato é uma coisa
importante pra gente mudar o mundo
porque se a gente deixar de acreditar
que uma pessoa pode transformar uma
realidade como é que a gente vai mudar
alguma coisa e isso fez muito sentido
para mim porque o começo da minha vida
tinha sido definido por uma pessoa com
esperança é que a minha mãe quando
estava grávida de mim
ela teve rubéola e descobriu bem no
início da gravidez
e aí naquela época ela tinha duas opções
ou a interromper a gravidez porque
segundo todos os médicos dela a chance
era de 95% do feto só na ser
comprometido todo o sistema neurológico
inclusive com um risco de cegueira
surdez até microcefalia
ou ela seguia um outro caminho de geada
só pela intuição dela buscando métodos
alternativos
numa atitude de resiliência mas também
de uma esperança íntima em nós duas e eu
cresci muito inspirada por isso com
muita vontade de trabalhar com alguma
coisa que pudesse diminuir o abismo da
esperança não para que todo mundo
tivesse a mesma atitude da minha mãe
necessariamente mas para que todas as
pessoas sentirem capazes de fazer suas
próprias escolhas que elas tivessem toda
a informação disponível pra isso mas que
principalmente elas não perdessem essa
inspiração essa vontade de levantar da
cadeira e achar soluções e nada me
parecia tão oportuno pra isso como um
momento em que a gente está assistindo
filmes porque hoje em dia é um momento
que você consegue parar se inspirar se
emocionar e se informar de tudo está
acontecendo no mundo ao mesmo tempo
então insistindo nessa ideia eu resolvi
buscar mais experiência e fui para los
angeles que quatro anos lá entre
fazendo-me após e também trabalhando nos
estúdios
a minha ideia era absurdo o máximo
possível de experiência em como contar
boas histórias para depois voltar para o
brasil e fazer filmes que juntassem
diversão e emoção com inspiração
informação hoje no brasil junto com os
meus sócios e muitos parceiros que a
gente juntou ao longo dos anos
a gente montou uma produtora focada em
fazer filmes e séries de interesse
coletivo
o criança a alma do negócio por exemplo
é um filme que fala sobre os danos da
publicidade infantil e ajudou muito aqui
esse assunto fosse cada vez mais
discutido no brasil a ponto de virar
inspiração para o tema da prova do enem
no ano passado para mais de 9 milhões de
jovens muito além do peso também
inspirou muitas políticas públicas no
combate à obesidade infantil como o
projeto da prefeitura de são paulo muito
além do prato inspirado no filme e é
muito bom eu começar a perceber que
realmente os filmes podem inspirar
transformações reais
mas essa escolha esse caminho não foi
tão fácil assim
muito além do peso por exemplo foi um
desastre de bilheteria nos cinemas mesmo
supostamente falando de um assunto que
interessaria uma a cada três famílias
brasileiras que já estão passando por
isso dentro de casa
reunindo as informações dos maiores
especialistas no assunto e retratando
famílias reais que qualquer um consegue
identificar
mesmo assim o filme foi visto por duas
mil pessoas nos cinemas e ali eu conheci
as barreiras da acessibilidade e do
desinteresse
então não bastava só fazer filmes que
fossem relevantes e importantes e
urgentes para a vida de todo mundo
porque no brasil como em muitos países
do mundo os lugares que mais precisam da
informação são elas - chegam aqui por
exemplo só 7% das cidades têm cinemas e
só 1% desses se encontram nas periferias
então como é que as pessoas vão chegar a
esses conteúdos
além disso eu fui visitar o interior do
mato grosso
e lá a dona do cinema local e mostrou
uma coisa que eu fiquei mais
impressionado mesmo com os ingressos a
r$1 ninguém é o cinema
ninguém se interessava mas os bares ao
redor da praça estão sempre lotadas
então tentando achar uma forma prática
de lidar com todas essas adversidades a
gente resolveu experimentar uma outra
saída
a gente pegou aquele filme que tinha
sido mal na bilheteria dos cinemas
liberamos gratuitamente na internet para
ver o que acontecer e aí pra nossa
surpresa a gente passou de 2000 para
2011 de pessoas interessadas e isso me
provou que já tem sim muita gente
interessada em se informarem se inspirar
através de filmes mas que realmente a
gente vai ter que ser cada vez mais
criativo para enfrentar as barreiras da
acessibilidade com essa motivação a
gente siga em frente sempre fazendo
filmes atrelados à mobilização social
para cada causa lutando para empoderar
as pessoas e diminuindo esse abismo da
esperança
nosso próximo filme por exemplo fala
muito disso o começo da vida ele mostra
como que a gente pode formar uma nova
humanidade
se a gente cuidar melhor dos primeiros
anos de vida das nossas crianças e para
que ele de fato chegue mais longe ele já
vai nascer em maio como um movimento
global onde ongs e especialistas
artistas e famílias do mundo inteiro se
reúnem para divulgar uma mesma causa e
assim em rede que a gente está chegando
cada vez mais pessoas
só que a barreira da acessibilidade no
brasil e muitos países não mudou muito
existem filmes inspiradores relevantes
transformadores acontecendo no mundo
todos os dias eu já tinha aprendido que
se a gente juntar filmes relevantes com
pessoas que já estão interessadas
as mudanças no mundo e acontecer
naturalmente
só que eu achava lá atrás que era uma
distância simples entre uma tela um sofá
e uma pipoca para mudar o mundo estava
ficando cada vez mais complexo porque
além da falta de espaços
os filmes estão cada vez mais
dificuldade de serem encontrados pelas
pessoas nesse mar infinito de
informações na internet
então a gente começou a pensar e se
existe um lugar que você buscar se pelo
seu tema de interesse e ali você
descobrir se é onde estão disponíveis os
melhores filmes pra você se interessa
por aqueles assuntos mas se mesmo assim
você descobrisse que o filme que você
quer não está disponível nenhum formato
na sua cidade
esse lugar de dessas ferramentas
necessárias para você mesmo organizar
sua exibição em qualquer lugar nessa
escola é só praça na sua casa até
podendo fazer download de repente de
materiais extras do assunto caso você
queira fazer um debate depois de
assistir o filme com os amigos e sabe
aquele momento que a gente termina de
ver um filme e está super emocionado no
final e tem vontade de levantar da
cadeira para fazer alguma coisa
transformar as coisas mas não tem a
menor idéia de por onde começar
já senti isso várias vezes
seria legal também que nesse lugar a
gente fosse guiado por ação seja pra
fazer uma doação virar um voluntário
assinar uma petição e foi com esse sonho
para reúne todas as idéias que a gente
buscou uma forma de conectar filmes
pessoas e causas
no mesmo lugar um ponto de encontro
online gratuito
o vídeo aqui toda vez que eu penso
encontro
eu lembro de uma frase que aliás eu
aprendi no filme ela dizia assim o
diálogo só acontece quando as pessoas
estão preparadas a serem transformadas
pelo encontro e é por isso que eu
acredito que toda pessoa que se encontra
de verdade com outras pessoas pode
começar uma mudança espalhando uma ideia
assistindo um filme e se emocionando
gerando reflexões que promovem diálogos
provocando mudanças a cada simples
encontro
obrigada